2010 est une année qui a débuté sur les
chapeaux de roue avec un record celui de
robert marchand le 4 janvier au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le sportif
réalise 22 points 5 km à 150 g problème
là les dégâts liés lady gaga minutes
sinon j'arrête déboîté boulvé justement
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines théâtre d'un
autre record mais cette fois-ci handball
féminin le 25 mars le club d'issy paris
s'impose contre brest en championnat
devant plus de 5000 spectateurs
du jamais vu franchement moi une grosse
salle bonne ambiance et je pense que
c'est grâce à 55
aujourd'hui on a réussi et franchement
on avait à coeur de bien faire ici sur
le stade vélodrome est montré qu' on a
des très belles salles à paris à
quelques kilomètres du vélodrome
nationale le dimanche 5 mars bois d'arcy
yake la première étape du paris nice les
22 équipes cyclistes ont dû affronter le
vent il a plu pendant les 148 km de
course entre la vallée de chevreuse et
plaisir c'est finalement le français
arnaud démare qui remporte la course
dans les derniers mètres
ça a été une étape absolument magnifique
peut être la plus belle étape de
paris-nice plus belle première étape de
paris nice depuis 20 ans 25 ans les
politiques ont également joué des coudes
au début de l'année 2010 est pour
remporter la victoire le 29 janvier à
paris benoît hamon alors député de la
11e circonscription des yvelines
remporte les primaires du parti
socialiste devant manuel valls 58%
nationalement 89% à trappes
je suis hyper content maintenant tout
reste à faire parce que c'est qu'une
primaire maintenant en route pour la
présidentielle et vers la victoire
7 mai prochain quelques semaines plus
tard c'est finalement un ancien ministre
qui s'illustre le soir du premier tour
des élections présidentielles le 23
avril
emmanuel macron se qualifie pour le
second tour en devançant marine le pen
de trois points au niveau national
benoît hamon termine 5ème avec 6 36% des
voix dans les yvelines le candidat dans
marche remporte les suffrages avec 29 %
juste devant françois fillon des
républicains j'étais venu juste pour
faire un bout de parcours sur un projet
citoyen la grande marche et de la voilà
il a poussé il nous a donné confiance en
nous
le début d'année 2010 est a été
également marquée par une triste
première dans les yvelines à rhinocéros
du parc zoologique de thoiry a été tué
par balle pendant la nuit pour cecon par
un braconnier une des défenses a été
sectionné à la tronçonneuse un fait
inédit en europe
on part quand même du principe que les
animaux qui sont dans un parc zoologique
son protégé justement du braconnage
qu'on rencontre dans la cure donc là
c'est très très choquant dans les
yvelines plusieurs projets sont sortis
également de terre sur les quatre
premiers mois de l'année 50 ans neeve in
inauguré en janvier le ski qu près de la
gare un incubateur pour
l'entrepreneuriat dédié à une trentaine
de start up du territoire du côté de
plaisir les travaux sur les fresques
géantes dans le quartier du vélib ou
débuté en avril
au total huit dessins géants imaginé par
les habitants sont dessinés dans ce
quartier le 4000 habitants d'ici 2020 le
7 avril après cinq ans de travaux le
tout premier temple mormon de france
métropolitaine a été inauguré aux
chaînés en présence de l'ancien candidat
à la présidentielle américaine mitt
romney membres des mormons
coût total de l'opération 70 millions
d'euros entièrement financés par
l'église st les membres de l'église ici
en france ils ont l'occasion d'aller aux
tables à madrid du doigt en suisse mais
finalement nous avons ensemble aux
chaînés début 2017 le musée de la ville
de saint quentin en yvelines a rouvert
ses portes après 18 mois de travaux 6000
objets sont exposés sur les 280 m² de la
structure il y avait besoin de doubler
cet espace parce que celui du musée
était devenu vraiment très restreint
dans l'ancien musée
ça fait plaisir de voir
un an et demi de travail de travaux
aussi qu'ils aboutissent dernières
images de ses quatre premiers mois dans
les yvelines un compte à rebours géant
est installé le 31 janvier à l'entrée de
la gare de saint quentin en yvelines sur
l'objectif affiché les jours qui nous
séparent de la ryder cup la plus grande
compétition de golf au monde qui
opposera les européens aux américains
septembre 2018 au golf national à
guyancourt
l'horloge qui a annoncé 6 en quatre
jours ce jour-là affiche moins de deux
cent soixante neuf jours aujourd'hui